[Music]
one of our portfolio companies went from
stuck to $10 million per year in 4
months and in this video I'm going to
walk you through the actual marketing
and sales tactics we use so that you can
apply those things to your business too
so one of the newer companies in our
portfolio was doing about 570,000 per
month and they had plateaued there month
after month after month for about 6
months so let's start with marketing so
we had in this business a webinar-based
business meaning it's running ads to a
video that the founder would get on and
basically pitch a call to find out more
all right so I'm going to give you
current state so our show rate for this
webinar was 18% which is really not good
you want it to be 25 or kind of higher
the schedule rate from the webinar
meaning people who booked to then take a
sales call I actually don't have that
number but we didn't prove it so I'll
tell you what we ended up doing and
before we made these changes we were
getting 58 calls booked per webinar all
right so that's where we started so so
the problem starting with this was the
show rate so the issue is that we were
only doing one time per week for the
founder so they only wanted to do kind
of like one pitch per week and the issue
is that means that if somebody books on
let's call it Monday and she does the
webinar on Sunday then it means all of
this time in between is where people
could forget about it get busy fall off
and essentially just not show up even
though we paid to get the opdate so we
did four things to actually fix this so
number one is that we introduced a long
email sequence we had nine emails that
we went that went out and these were we
just basically improved the email so we
uh simplified the language we put it
more benefit driven uh and basically
sold the reason they should attend and
we tried to hit it from different angles
so we try to hit from pain we try to hit
from speed we try to hit it from ease we
try to hit it from being stuck in
plateaued because the big thing that you
always have to remember is that pain is
what drives motivation all right that's
what gets people to actually take action
the second thing we did is we added an
SMS because if people uh aren't showing
up then you want to communicate in more
places and more ways and so some people
me like me specifically I'm way more
text responsive than I am email
responsive I rarely check my email but I
do check my texts the next thing that we
did on top of that was within the emails
we actually did some sort of behavior
response all right so you're like what
the hell does that mean and so Behavior
response means that if someone engages
in any piece of content they click they
uh they open it we then sent them behind
the scenes content so think about this
is exclusive or secret stuff that made
it show that we saw what they were doing
which is also something every business
wants is like oh W this is pretty cool I
didn't know they could do something like
this just showing kind of some more
sophistication in marketing and then the
fourth thing that we did was again with
more places more ways we had voicemail
messages that we sent out to them and so
that means that we cover people who like
text people who like email people like
voicemail and then we also had video
essentially for people who took an
engagement so we had all four ways that
people consume information that we added
in prior to the webinar and so one of
the other things that you can do
obviously besides pain is that you add
in proof and so you can alternate
between proof and pain but big picture
is that you always want to use the value
equation which you've got dream which is
what's the big thing that they want to
have happen you've got risk so you want
to decrease the risk this is where proof
comes in and you want to uh decrease the
time so that's speed and you want to
decrease the hard right which is you
want to make it easy and so we want to
show how easy it is how fast it is how
risk-free it is with proof and we want
to make sure that we're very accurately
describing what they want to have happen
yeah if you especially have people who
have you know your avatar doesn't
respond to email because sometimes there
are Industries you know if you're in
finance a lot of people respond to
emails if you're in painters uh and
maybe bluecollar workers you might have
fewer responses to emails so that's okay
so instead it's like making sure that we
have these multiple ways like text for
example has a 95 to 99% open rate so
people will get the message and so
obviously you don't want to abuse it but
having just a few strategically placed
texts can massively increase the show up
rate to things and I would bet that if I
had to put between all of these things
this would be the biggest one that had
the increase in show up rates and so
because we had ctas inside the email to
get them to engage we also long-term
keep the health of our email account
because it shows that we're not just
spamming people instead people are
getting our emails they're opening them
they're reading them they're taking an
action all those increase the overall
health of your uh your email server and
your deliver ability and so that way you
can continue to get your emails
delivered rather than getting into the
promo tabs is getting a little bit
tactical but you get into a second tab
with an email which is like oh no one
ever checks the spam folder essentially
the big reason that we have to do all
this stuff is because no one remembers
what they signed up for this morning let
alone five days ago and so we do this
because you have to remind them and
don't worry about quote bothering people
now do you want to send five a day no
that's probably not smart but if you
send one reminder a day between a
certain time and an event there's
nothing wrong with that and so the most
important part of the sequence I'll tell
you right now is 24 hours before so
you're thinking the night before you
have the morning of which is am and then
one hour prior these are the three most
important reminders that you want to
send out these are the ones that you
definitely want to have as SMS so you
might be wondering well how much did we
increase the show up break percentage
well we went from 18% to 24% which means
that this increase was a 33% increase
right off the bat and so one of the
things I think is one of the most
underutilized ways to make a business
more money like a lot of people obsess
about close rates and we're going to
talk about what we did with sales but
you can get a 33% increase in show up
rates and have the same result as having
a 33% increase in close rates but
getting 33% more people to show up is
usually way easier and you're able to
automate a lot of that to a great degree
so it's onetime work to have permanent
increases in revenue and profit rather
than having to consistently drill a team
on how to close which you absolutely
should do it just takes more work so the
next problem that we had was that people
who were actually attending so now we
have our 24% of people who are showing
up is that they weren't actually
choosing to book a call and so problem
number two no bookings right and so what
we did is we solved a few things inside
of how we structured the webinar to get
way more people to show up and I'll show
you just how many so the first thing
that we did is we actually looked at
what was and so I think people skip this
step but like this is the real work is
you look at the webinar you look at the
attendance rates you look at the drop
off points you look at where there
spikes in engagement engagement are
going to be the interest points where
you're like okay this is something maybe
we should expand some of this stuff and
where you have huge drop offs then
you're like o we need to improve this
and so for us we saw we were losing a
ton of people right at the beginning of
the webinar and so we're like okay this
is where we're going to put most of our
attention which by the way if you're
doing anything content sales webinars
whatever the first five minutes and even
the first 60 seconds is where you should
be obsessing even in a different company
we have in our portfolio which does a
tremendous amount greater volume than
this particular company we rescripted
the first five minutes of uh
presentation and got a 20% increase in
close rates Ju Just redoing 5 minutes
and it was on a three-hour presentation
so based on the research we did four
things the first thing we did is we
scripted a faster intro basically
getting to the point much faster and
being clearer about why they are here
and what they're going to get from it
and so if you're like well what would
that actually look like well it actually
follows the exact same format that we
use for our content which is proof
promise plan so proof is is hey I helped
someone just like you and you want them
to identify with the proof that you were
showing so they can approximate oh this
is just like me the promise is clearly
defining exactly what they're going to
get both from the webinar and
potentially after the webinar and then
the plan is to set expectations for how
the next 60 90 however many minutes your
presentation is so they know where
they're going and the key Point here
with all the faster in stuff is you just
want to get to the meet when I look at a
beginner sales call or beginner sales
presentation or vssl video sales letter
often times people spend a minute 2
minutes just like Meandering like trying
to figure out what they're saying and
they don't know that they're losing like
40% of Their audience in the first two
minutes before they figure out what
they're going to start saying so get to
the point number two is we mention live
that this is live so this was a live
webinar they were doing and the thing is
is that we weren't actually showing so
we're incurring the cost of being live
but we want to say the date you want to
say the time you want to say the weather
you want to say any current events right
these are all things that give
indications that this is happening right
now and so for whatever reason and I
don't know why this is but when you do
live stuff it works better no idea why I
just know that it works and so we want
to lean into the fact that it's actually
happening and so mind you if you do an
automated webinar or you do a video SI
letter that's recorded there's nothing
wrong with that obviously it gives you
scale because you can't do a webinar
every hour of every day but in general
if you are struggling to make something
automated convert better I would
recommend going live for a while and
doing it more frequently live so you get
the reping get it tighter and get the
benefit of just the magic of liveness so
the next thing we did is we had a
takeaway all right so you can always you
know it's like uh the only guy the girl
wants at the bar is the guy who's not
chasing them whatever right and so
there's two main things that we changed
tactically to make this a little bit
more of a takeaway so number one is that
we were very clear about who our
qualifications were so we said listen we
only sell people who are this this or
this if you are below this or above this
or adjacent to this this is not for you
and so by clearly stating those things
we got to ward off the wrong people and
magnetize the right people to be like oh
this is actually just for me the next
thing we did was we put scarcity in play
all right and so this is one of my
favorite ways of ethically providing
scarcity which is saying we only have
this many times to take calls or
consults because I only have two guys on
my team I only have four guys on my team
so we only have this many slots and so
typically we will book out of slots
within this period of time and so if you
say typically then that does excuse you
as long as more than half the time that
does happen or often times you can say
that uh you can preface it in that way
not an exact language that it happens
often right and then with the scarcity
you just say the actual constraint you
have and so I see this as one of the
most underutilized scarcity strategies
in existence if you're an agency and you
can only take on five customers because
you couldn't take on 100 anyways then
say you can only take on five customers
if you can only take 20 phone calls then
say you can only take 20 and if you know
that there's the urgency component which
is it's first come first serve then say
that and so by doing the qualification
and then adding the scarcity and a
little bit of urgency around its first
Comfort serve and we we can only service
so many that though that sounds simple
people don't do it and yes it does work
so the fourth thing is we uh I would say
this is scarcity on steroids you're like
wait I thought you just did scarcity
well we just put more scarcity in so we
did a couple of things around this but
we added proof all right so one is this
is theoretical but as soon as people
begin to take action we want to show
proof that they've done it so the first
thing that we did is we said hey as soon
as you do book let me know in the chat
and so let me know in the chat then
shows this proof that's happening in the
chat that people are booking all right
so that was number one the next thing we
did is that by doing this it creates an
open loop and so it's like if you were
on a sales call say hey I'll wait here
and then I'll make sure I can see it on
my side then what we did is we did call
outs so it says hey I see that Rosie
booked hey I see that John booked hey I
see that Susan booked right so we can
say in real time and it creates this
this frenzy around booking and the last
thing that we did is that you actually
want to call out the soldout times now
this is a little bit of language use
here but we say the word sold out
because it again it creates more buying
Behavior and pre-framed the sale and so
You' say hey Wednesday is sold out
Thursday is sold out Friday is sold out
and so as the times are booking out we
want to show that even though we said we
have a 100 slots we basically chunk it
down again and say oh this day is sold
the morning is sold out like if you're
like getting worried about like you're
not even sell just say hey the morning
on Wednesday is sold out up the
afternoon on Wednesday sold out maybe
you only have three slots whatever but
you can still basically approximate some
sort of mini urgency mini scarcity by
just saying what has been taken and it's
completely compliant because you're just
stating the facts and telling the truth
and by the way if you're a business
owner and you are doing a million bucks
a year and you are looking to scale and
either you're not scaling as fast as you
want or you just feel like you're stuck
I get it either way um and these tactics
are helping you out if you want specific
help on your specific business we open
up dates at our headquarters
sporadically to invite people out and so
if you want to see if we have
availability and you want to see if you
qualify you can go to acquisition. comom
my team will get on the phone worst case
we'll try and set you up with something
that could help you in the meantime and
best case we see out here in Vegas and I
would love to meet you and help you grow
so those four tactics that I just
outlined for you gave us a
33% increase in our booking rate from
the webinar so we got a 33% lift in
people who are showing up and of the now
greater amount of people we got another
33% lift uh in increased number of
people who then booked calls and so our
total book costs went from 58 to survey
says
102 so nearly a double this was 77%
increase in total book calls from the
same ADP and if we had only done that
that could have just absolutely
demolished it for the business we could
have done nothing else and we could have
rode enough in the sunset but we wanted
to make more and so let's talk about
sales now so for the sales process all
we're really looking at here is Clos
rate now technically you could have a
drop off between the uh booking webinar
and the show up on the sales call that
was not a constraint for this business
it had super high show up rates I didn't
even lift it here because it wasn't
worth doing and it didn't change because
we didn't really focus there because it
wasn't the main thing but we did have a
low close rate once people are actually
showing up to the sales call and so we
focused there too and so the Clos rate
before this was 14% so to be really
clear this is bad you don't want a 14%
close rate that's tough especially after
a webinar or some sort of long selling
event so we were just missing the ball
here and so we took some steps to fix it
and we chose to fix it in four ways and
so I'm going to start at the front and
move backwards so number one the thing
that we had was bad framing all right so
what a lot of people don't know is just
like in the beginning of a video proof
promise plan right what you say at the
very beginning has a massive uh impact
on what people end up doing at the end
and so most people do look at the end
rather than looking at the beginning and
how they got introduced to the sale to
begin with and so in the beginning a lot
of the team that they had was kind of
wasting time trying to like build report
like how's your week going great I know
we've got limited time here blah blah
blah blah blah like no we wanted to fix
the theum and get right to the point so
let me tell you what the bad intro was
before this so it was like hey how's it
going my name's so and so how's your
week going oh cool great uh I know we
have limited time here so ready to jump
in you know do you have a pen and paper
to take notes with right now that was
the old way of doing it and I think
that's a fairly common way of doing it
but I tend to think that there's a
better way to do it and so that's what
I'm going to share with you and so what
we started with was hey my name's John
I'm here from this company and I have a
background in ABC which is specific to
whatever problem that you want to solve
I work closely with so and so edified
person that you saw in the webinar and I
would love to know what resonated most
with you now they're going to then
answer because now now we're we're we're
reminding them the value that they got
on the webinar and kind of getting them
back in that state where they took
action and we say great so the real
purpose of this call is to see if you
qualify for our guarantee not everyone
does and it's really based on these
three factors so if it's B2B you'd be
like business size industry and you're
being the owner now fundamentally you're
going to be going through b which is
budget Authority need timing and you
want to use those as the qualifications
for the guarantee now if you have
guarantees obviously this is sexy now
instead of a guarantee you could also
say hey we want to make sure that you
qualify for the bonus or hey I want to
make sure that you qualify for starting
this time it doesn't really matter what
it is but the thing is you're
immediately taking it away and saying
hey I'm not here to sell I'm here to
First make sure that I can even give you
something and automatically they're
leaning in and they're like o I want
something that I'm not immediately
having so you're in the driver's seat
they're the ones who are on the other
side hoping to earn your favor and so
then after that you can clarify what it
is it's like and to be clear the bonus
is X Y andz or hey to be clear you know
our guarantee uh we have to be strict
it's kind of like college admissions
whatever uh and if you don't qualify
this is what we're going to set you up
with and help you out but if you do do
then we'll start buying back some time
and make you some more money or and
we'll start x y and Zing benefit that we
originally promised on the webinar and
so the big thing and this is like it's
it's everywhere through the entire
process from marketing to sales to
customer uh success all all the way
through is that you want to have
congruence all right is you want to have
you want to basically have the customer
feel like you have this Baton Pass
between every single step in the
business and so from the ad to what they
see as the headline for the webinar once
they opt in the first few lines of the
webinar should match with the headline
that they opted in for once they get on
the call it should match what you talked
about on the webinar once they get sold
the onboarding and success person should
be matching what they said on the sales
call and this sounds so simple and yet
no one does it and literally if you have
complete alignment all the way through
your process you will make so much more
money and this sounds simple and it is
simple to understand but hard to do
because you have to coordinate multiple
parties along the same line but this is
what creates streamlined lubricated
sales we're talking Diddy Lube so the
second part of the sale is where you get
in Discovery so in the beginning it's
like what what's the frame you're
setting what's the agenda we had a much
more takeaway version that was still
congruent with what was promised on the
webinar the next thing is Discovery and
so a lot of people waste time in
Discovery and this is where they get
caught they get caught in traps and I I
made a whole video about this you can
probably find it on my channel um but
they go into traps and so traps are
basically where you get too far in the
weeds you get too into the details and
both you and the prospect forget why why
you're there to begin with and so you
want to stay chunked up at the highest
level humanly possible because when you
stay chunked up you can focus on the few
things that matter that are going to
move the needle that are ultimately
going to be tied to the biggest Roi
around whatever it is that you sell stop
getting cute and sales calls and so a
lot of sales people will start doing
this as they get a little bit more
experience and this is a mistake and so
this is why sometimes you have somebody
come into your sales team they they you
know they quickly ramp up they do well
and all of a sudden their sales number
starts slipping it's because they get
cute they get fancy they start to start
saying words that they've heard around
and trying to play business consultant
or start to play expert but they're not
the expert because they're not the ones
doing the delivery and so you want to
always get out of these very detail
oriented questions because as soon as
they ask those questions then they're
the ones in control of the conversation
and not you because the way you answer
could to turn them off and say oh
actually I didn't want that but now
you're the one answering their questions
they're in control so during Discovery
you ask the questions they give the
answers and you stay high level to make
sure that you're staying on the line to
get to the end once you've gone through
Discovery and you've hit on the pain
you've clearly defined a reason they
should be motivated to take action then
we go into the pitch all right now I am
a big advocate of a three-pillar
framework and I talk about this in the
closure process and let me tell you some
advanced stuff on this so the more
do-it-yourself done with you the product
is the more you want it to be simple you
want it to be 1 12 3 ABC whatever the
more implementation you have the more
done for for you it is the more you want
to show here's 11 steps 27 steps that we
follow because what you want someone to
see is oh my God this is so much work
and then you say right so they believe
that it works but they don't want to do
the work and so you're like yeah oh I
believe that if I do 38 steps to improve
my YouTube videos they'll improve but
can you just do it for me and that's
where you want them to go and but if
you're selling a solution that they're
supposed to do a certain percentage of
the work or a greater percentage of the
work then you want it to be as simple as
humanly possible and if you're curious
like why is Do-it yourself and done with
you more or less same is that I actually
see done with you as basically a d
do-it-yourself sale plus accountability
help troubleshooting getting you unstuck
so it's really just that theoretically
if you just follow the steps you could
do it yourself but just to make sure
that you're successful will add this
extra help in rather than oh we're going
to do it all for you which is a true
done for you offer and so instead of the
three-pillar pitch what this company was
doing was they had a feature pitch or a
feature stack so they were making it
seem really complicated and having way
too many steps and overwhelming the
prect but then after the pro prospect's
overwhelmed and Confused it was like
great you got that so you're going to do
it and then you're like uh right and so
they're like no thank you now if you're
like hey all of that I'll do it
different pitch three-pillar pitch if
you're not sure stick with that usually
crushes and if you're like wait I have
six steps in my process you just Chunk
Up it means like you just gather two of
them together and just make it a larger
bucket and one tiny tweak that we added
before the pitch was basically getting
them to invite us to sell them and so we
said hey given everything that you just
said and you're doing X and revenue you
mean y qualifications uh and the fact
that your challenge is this I think that
we'll be able to help you out and that
you'd be a great fit and our experience
is in solving this exact problem for
your Ty type of person and if you want I
can uh walk you through that but where
do you want to go from here and so then
they have to say no please walk me
through that and then basically they're
giving you permission to launch into the
three pillar pitch now this last step
step four was actually execution and so
there's a lot of things that we did here
and so uh this is not me selling you a
done with you solution this is me
actually just trying to help you out um
so we did many things to improve
execution and so we actually had a
conversation with the founder um and
they said you know uh I watched some of
these Discovery recordings and they look
pretty bad and we said yeah well when
was the last time you roleplayed
Discovery with your team and they were
like uh I don't we're like hm
interesting and so what we did and this
is going to be mind-blowing to you is
number one is we role played we actually
had the team practiced it all right and
uh this isn't with wigs and handcuffs we
actually had them roleplay it with one
another but maybe that increases Stakes
so you can do whatever you want on your
sales team um the next thing is that
there wasn't very good tracking and so
we wanted to track kpis more closely and
so sometimes if you have two chunked up
kpis if you just have Clos rate for
example it doesn't give you more kind
like double click ability to look more
granularly into how a closer is doing
and so we want to see okay what
percentage of people are you getting to
show what percentage of people um when
you're on the phone are you actually
making the offer to uh what percentage
of people are missing because of what
specific obstacle are not and so this
gives us a lot more insight into how
each individual closer is doing and then
from there that allows us to personalize
the coaching that we have for each of
those individual sales guys now if
you're still looking at this and you're
like man what else was there well
sometimes it's a who thing which is do I
believe that you can train anyone to
sell yes do I think it's worth it to
train everyone to sell no some people
just start further back on the line is
it's not worth the resources for the
business and so we ruthlessly prioritize
who gets the best calls who gets the
best times and we do that by who closes
the most and if you eventually get kind
of weeded out you can almost manage
someone out of sales if they
consistently Show Low returns for us
giving them and feeding them
opportunities and so what we did is if
you were below kpi we cut your calendar
in half if you're still below kpi you
have basically a week or two to prove
yourself or you're out and so the next
thing that we did is that uh we routed
the best leads to the best closers so
best to best and this is one of my my
favorite ways to uh to increase sales
overall like if your best closes get the
best leads you'll sell more stuff if
your worst closes get the worst leads
you'll lose the least and so this is an
optimization for any sales process
across any business and then finally and
this is a big one we incentivize the
paid and fo because I think this
particular business if I'm not mistaken
uh the closur got paid the same if they
closed or didn't but I prefer to close
off cash collected all right which means
that the closers have the same incentive
as you and so let's say you have a
$110,000 thing that you sell well if if
you have a payment plan let's say that's
five payments of 2K then the closer is
going to get call it $200 for that
because they get just 10% of the $2,000
they close and if they get the paid in
full then they get $1,000 for that sale
so they get paid five times more and so
this incentivizes closers to actually
close instead of these kind of like limp
wristed closes they're rock hard wrecked
closes no flaccid closes in this house
uh and that way you know uh that the the
prospect actually has been sold on it
and is more likely to stick with it in
the long term which for real is actually
an important thing and often times these
types of issues come up like these lacks
of execution when a Founder gets a
little too far away and so I like to say
you want to know where the bodies are
buried like you want to know in every
Department what is going wrong as a
founder and if you get too far away from
it then you don't know which means you
don't really add value because you have
no context and I think a lot of people
get too far away from sales or
especially Revenue generation too
quickly because they like want to scale
and they want to give you know hand off
responsibility to people underneath of
them but if when you hand stuff off
stats go down you have abdicated not
delegated when you delegate stats stay
the same or go up because theoretically
if you give someone who has equal skill
more time to do it because they have
more time than you then stat should
improve and so when you give it to
somebody who has less skill than you and
you didn't prepare them and you didn't
give them a checklist then it's more
likely that stuff's going to go down and
that's where you have to stay there and
they stay sty side by side with you
until they get it all right and so with
all of this stuff and you're like holy
cow that actually when you think about
it bad framing for you know we had to
make it congruent we we we chunked up
Discovery to make sure they avoided
traps and stayed high level we
simplified it to a three-pillar pitch
with a little bit of a pre pitch and we
did all the these things on execution to
make sure that the team actually was
reading the script and actually saying
the words the right way the result of
all of this work
was we got to a
35% close rate so that was more than a
double whatever that is 2.4 I think 2.4x
increase in close rate monster all right
so we're going to talk about the results
of this and at the end I'm going to give
you the takeaways that I had for this
business that you can use so the result
of all that work is we took our CA from
$
5,763 to
$2,868 so more than or about cut in half
what it cost us to get a customer on top
of that we went from a 1.6 2 which is
very bad Raz to a
3.96 Raz much better and we took our
revenue from 5 169,000 to
860k per month so we passed our $10
million run rate and we have sustained
that since these improvements have
occurred and then profit we got to a
30.7% profit margin off of that and so
now this business is making $250
$300,000 a month in profit whereas
before it was kind of plateaued and just
kind of teetering at that edge so let's
talk about the big takeaways so what you
can do from this for your business no
matter what size you're at so number one
is that you have to keep the main thing
the main thing obviously this business
was still generating a decent amount of
monthly Revenue but the thing is is that
people discount how much an increase in
Revenue can prop disproportionately drop
to the bottom line and so let's say
you've got a business that has 10%
margins if you can increase Revenue by
50% you can in a very real way
disproportionately increase profit so
you could increase profit by 5x when you
increase Revenue by 10 or 20% and so
understanding the relationship between
revenue and profit is something that a
lot of business owners don't do and so
sometimes it's cool to trim from the
bottom line but it's so much better to
dra the top line and have that extra
Revenue fall through and so big picture
here all the way chunked up the
constraint was acquisition we weren't
getting enough customers now underneath
of getting enough customers you'll
notice that there's just a pipeline of
things that all could be improved it's
like can we improve our CTR can we
improve our opit can we proove our
schedule can we proove our show right
can we prove uh can we improve the close
rate and so what we did is we just
looked at all of them and the key Point
here is that we actually looked and so
when we tried to improve the webinar we
weren't just like shooting from the hip
we're like where are people dropping off
let's fix it when we looked at the sales
we're like where are people suffering
well if you're watching the calls you
can see that wow the discovery sucks all
right well then we need to focus more
there at the front and I will also o put
this point is that the front is where a
lot of times where the cash is so in the
beginning of the webinar we pre-loaded
it in the beginning of the call we
pre-loaded it right before we did the
pitch we pre-frame it and so a lot of
times people don't understand how
powerful the frame is for setting the
expectation about what's about to happen
next the next one is execution over plan
all right so let me explain what I mean
by this if you have call it a mediocre
script and you have exceptional
execution you will still outperform
somebody who has an amazing script and
no one reads it right or you have an
amazing webinar deck but you still sound
terrible when you do it you're not going
to do as well as somebody who doesn't
have as much of a deck but sounds really
smooth and great and so a lot of times
this is the boring work that people
aren't willing to do they're not willing
to watch game tape they're not willing
to roleplay with the team they're not
willing to practice themselves when they
do repites or when they do presentations
or they're not willing to take a Content
piece get to the end of and be like you
know what we can do that better we can
do it again and so even for this video
we redid the intro five times before you
actually saw that and so you have to be
willing to repeat successful actions and
just get 5% better over and over and
over again because that betterness
across this whole thing compounds and so
one of the big things that I've learned
around improving anything is that you
can actually have measurement as
intervention and it's like okay that's a
big fancy word is that a is that a drug
rehab thing no that's not what I mean um
if you want someone to lose weight the
first step is to get them to measure
their weight and you can actually just
have someone measure their weight and
they will lose weight if you just have
someone report on their profit they will
make more profit if you just have them
report there show rates schedule rate
close rates and reinforce that on a
regular daily basis where it affects
their behavior in a Cadence where they
can change it then they will and so one
of the easiest things that you can do to
improve any business is start measuring
the stuff that matters and if you hate
looking at the stat you should look at
it twice because it means I want you to
feel the pain so that it causes you to
change and one of the bigest things is
that better is often times one of the
lower risk ways versus new all right so
if you want to expand or improve a
business let's say you're strugging for
whatever reason part of you wants to do
new because new is sexy new is fun new
shiny object but the thing is is that
what you're currently doing is already
proven to a certain degree and so simply
doing more or doing the same thing
better is a better risk adjusted move
because you already know this works and
so fundamentally if we get more people
to show we will close at least as many
as we did before if we pre-frame with
more urgency and get more people to book
we will close more sales on the next
call right is that fundamentally
thinking through this is that more or
getting an improvement to augment or get
better will always fundamentally in the
same system improve it and so just
focusing on those things which usually
just takes work will give you
disproportionate return and oftentimes
that drops to the bottom line and one of
the first rules of Entrepreneurship that
I have is use
what
you've got now if we look at the team
that they have had and the process they
had we didn't change them from a webinar
we didn't change them from a phone sale
we didn't even change their calendar or
availability but we just stated the
facts and tell the truth we said hey we
only have this many slots we only have
this many sales guys this is actually
live and so we wanted to reinforce the
things that we were already doing but
simply telling them that we were doing
it and you get zero benefits from doing
something that you do not communicate
everything in business is about
perceived benefits perceived scarcity
perceived urgency so if you have a
deadline but don't let people know there
is no deadline if you have scarcity
there's only so many slots you can take
but you don't let people know you have
no scarcity if you are live but you
don't tell people you're live you're
going to have the same effect as a
recorded webinar or as a recorded event
which eliminates the competitive
advantage that you did this to begin
with so we got greedy in this business
because YOLO why not uh so what we did
was we implemented an upsell and so
rather than covering this video because
this is front end I want to talk about
what we did in the upsell in this video
and if it's not out yet check this one
out